four years ago I had Patty momes on the
ropes back then if I had the lead in the
big game check I simply stopped trying
to
score are Aces good i i f
yay we will be back here with a
Vengeance a lot can change in 4
years Chiefs went from lovable
underdogs taking over the house that
always wins putting together a team to
take back what's ours right on brother
oh not like that Deo you play slot and
stay in motion and KD will be secretly
miked up so he can quietly let us know
what's going on okay so we've snuck in
enemy territory but I don't think they
suspect anything CMC we'll need you to
go on a big run I have 25 sixes then you
all put the pressure on them I wouldn't
do that if I were you it's against the
law what law the green law there's too
much heat on us we need someone they
wouldn't expect a real nobody someone
irrelevant I know just the
guy herie isn't it it's the man scramble
how you'd like to make a lot of money
well that LE minimum you son of a coach
I'm in we had to be careful they shorted
up their defense over the years and she
was always
watching but while they were distracted
bir scampered in P check use check P
check no us check Lucky Old Brock Hy
must have just gotten delt a good
hand pay that man his money like y'all
should really extend him but could he go
head-to-head with Patty
MVP in the big game you can only play it
safe for so
long I'm going for it not so fast
Chief I
call you don't have to call Rejoice
Millennials it's
[Music]
sure you know they wouldn't even be in
that game if it weren't for us also
Everyone likes to pretend it's Mahomes
versus py they literally never play at
the same time right we're the ones
facing pie wait shh she's
watching